où
[Musique]
moi je les crée j'en suis à l'origine
mais en aucun cas je l' ai réfléchi pour
que ça devienne quelque chose d'aussi
populaire
[Musique]
jeté à la mer à la rédaction stylelist
est assez rapidement à mes confrères
nous annonce qu'il ya une attaque à
charlie hebdo à ce moment là on ne
savait pas qui était décédé s'il y avait
eu des morts ou quoi et donc j'ai écrit
je suis charlie parce que je trouvais
que ça a donné un message un peu
d'espoir mais aussi d'appartenance j'ai
assez rapidement senti le besoin de
m'exprimer sur ce sujet parce que c'est
ça faisait partie de en tout cas de mon
enfance en tout cas pas forcément mon
éducation mais c'est ça faisait partie
de mon patrimoine personnel en fait même
si je n'ai jamais été un grand lecteur
de charlie hebdo c'est quelque chose qui
était voilà dans mon dans mon entourage
proche je travaille avec la pop culture
donc et il ya certains éléments de
l'histoire qui sont 2 qui deviennent des
éléments de pop culture mais aussi du
cinéma
spartacus quand un des prisonniers dit
je suis parti qu en fin il ya aussi bien
évidemment kennedy et là j'ai quand même
pas mal de mes confrères qui me disent
mais dis donc ton truc qui circule de
plus en plus la 2 3 heures après l afp
me contacter ou demandé de faire une
déclaration sur pourquoi j'ai fait ça et
de là tout s'est emballé le soir même
place de la république on s'est retrouvé
le mercredi soir on se retrouvait y
avait pas mal de monde
je commençais à avoir quand même pas mal
de
deux panneaux je suis charlie c'est là
où j'ai compris qu'il y avait ça me
dépasse et en fait ce qui est en train
de se passer se meut dépassé que ce
slogan avait trouvé un écho auprès de
pas mal de gens tout le monde pouvait y
mettre ce qu'ils voulaient dedans en
fait c'est un avantage maria
d'inconvénients ce que après il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens qui l'ont
surinterpréter déformés ils ont vu plein
de choses différentes dans ce dans ce
dans ce message dans ce slogan mais là
la première des symboliques en tout cas
c'est de défendre la liberté
d'expression et la liberté de la presse
j'ai parlé à la luz en premier et il m'a
dit un truc
franchement qui m'a fait je pense que
c'est le truc qui m'a soulagé le plus et
il m'est tombé dans les bras et m'a
serré dans les bras et m'a dit merci
pour ce que tu as fait je suis pas sûr
que l'on janvier aurait été ce qu'il a
été si tu avais pas fait ce que tu as
fait donc c'est quelque chose d'énorme
venant de dents des gens de charlie
parce que c'est forcément c'était aussi
pour eux que que je faisais ça et c'est
avant tout pour eux que je faisais ça
c'est devenu une sorte de comme on
appelle un même où on le prend le
décline et on ne digère et on le on ne
pourront créer quelque chose de
différent
c'est le propre de la pop culture à
partir d'un moment du moment où un
slogan devient populaire ou une image ou
une vidéo où peu importe c'est serré
interprété pour devenir autre chose je
trouve ça plutôt bien à certains
endroits je trouve ça plutôt dérangeant
quand c'est fait pour vanter les mérites
des terroristes ou
ou des idées d'extrême quelle qu'elle
soit
moi je peux être qu'être désolé de ça
mais en même temps c'est un slogan qui a
pas qui ne m'appartient pas qui
appartient à personne
donc c'est un slogan public je suis
assez surpris de l'ampleur de fait que
ce truc a fait quatre fois le tour du
monde que se retrouve à la fin du
générique des simpsons que enfin des
trucs comme assez stupéfait en coin